If you want more from the show, join The Rest Is History Club. And with Christmas coming, you can also gift a whole year of access to the history lover in your life. Just head to the restishistory.com and click Gifts. Canada's Wonderland is bringing the holiday magic this season with Winterfest on select nights now through January 3rd. Step into a winter wonderland filled with millions of dazzling lights, festive shows, rides and holiday treats. Plus, Coca-Cola is back with Canada's kindest community, celebrating acts of kindness nationwide with a chance at $100,000 donation for the winning community and a 2026 holiday caravan stop.
如果你想了解节目的更多内容，请加入“一切皆历史”俱乐部。圣诞节即将来临，你也可以为身边的历史爱好者赠送一整年的会员资格。只需访问 restishistory.com 并点击“礼物”。加拿大奇幻乐园在这个季节通过冬季狂欢节带来节日魔法，即日起至 1 月 3 日的特定夜晚开放。步入一个充满数百万耀眼灯光、节日表演、游乐设施和节日美食的冬季仙境。此外，可口可乐携手加拿大最善良的社区强势回归，在全国范围内庆祝善举，获胜社区将有机会获得 10,000 美元的捐款以及 2026 年节日大篷车巡游。
Learn more at canadaswunderland.com. When you're flying Emirates business class, sipping your favorite cocktail at our onboard lounge, you'll see that your vacation isn't really over until your flight is over. Fly Emirates, fly better. This episode is sponsored by Hive. Britain revolutionised the future with the might of industrial power. But now you can transform your own energy future and take control with the power of Hive.
访问 canadaswunderland.com 了解更多信息。当你乘坐阿联酋航空商务舱，在机上酒廊品尝最爱的鸡尾酒时，你会发现，只有当航程结束，假期才算真正结束。搭乘阿联酋航空，飞向更好。本集由 Hive 赞助。英国曾以工业力量重塑了未来的脉搏。但现在，你可以借助 Hive 的力量，改变并掌控你自己的能源未来。
Hive makes the most of the sun, with solar panels turning sunlight into greener electricity and enabling you to sell excess back to the grid. And Hive's thermostats make it possible for you to heat your home without lifting anything more than a thumb and an impressed brow. Their heat pumps draw warmth from the air and they keep it exactly where you want it. No smoke, no waste. Hive's EV charger lets your car charge quietly overnight. Recharging while you do too. Hive brings it all together.
Hive 充分利用阳光，通过太阳能电池板将阳光转化为更环保的电力，并使你能够将多余的电量卖回电网。Hive 的恒温器让你只需动动大拇指和赞许的眉头，就能温暖你的家。他们的热泵从空气中汲取热量，并将其保持在你希望的精确位置。没有烟雾，没有浪费。Hive 的电动汽车充电器让你的汽车在夜间静音充电。在你休息的同时进行充电。Hive 将这一切完美融合。
Heating, charging and solar. managed from one simple app in a quiet revolution. In the long history of power, Hive helps you finally know yours. Head to hivehome.com to find out more, subject to survey and suitability. Hive app compatible with selected technology. Paid for surplus requires SEG tariff. Hello everyone and welcome back to a Rest is History Beatles themed special and this is part two. It's the blue album to the red album of part one.
供暖、充电和太阳能，尽在一个简单的应用程序中掌控，这是一场无声的革命。在漫长的电力历史中，Hive 助你最终认清并掌控属于你的力量。前往 hivehome.com 了解更多详情，视勘测和适用性而定。Hive 应用程序兼容特定技术。售出多余电量需要开通 SEG 资费。大家好，欢迎回到《一切皆历史》披头士乐队主题特辑，这是第二部分。它是第一部分红专辑对应的蓝专辑。
We left you on an absolute cliffhanger. John Lennon has made unwise comments about Jesus and provoked outrage in the Bible Belt in the United States. And the problem for him is that the Beatles are due to go on a tour to the United States. So Conan O'Brien, who has replaced Dominic on this show because Dominic refuses to talk about the Beatles, because Conan, what we didn't perhaps go into in great detail in the first episode was the actual music. And before the Beatles go on the tour that will bring them to America and all the Jesus kerfuffle, they have recorded an album that many now see as their greatest album, Revolver. Are you a particular fan of Revolver?
我们在一个绝对悬念迭起的地方结束了上集。约翰·列农发表了关于耶稣的不明智言论，并在美国圣经带引发了众怒。而他面临的问题是，披头士乐队即将在美国进行巡演。因此，柯南·奥布莱恩取代了本节目的多米尼克，因为多米尼克拒绝谈论披头士。柯南，我们在第一集中可能没有深入探讨的是实际的音乐本身。在披头士踏上带他们去美国并引发一系列耶稣风波的巡演之前，他们录制了一张现在许多人认为是他们最伟大专辑的专辑——《Revolver》（左轮手枪）。你是《左轮手枪》的狂热粉丝吗？
Huge fan of Revolver. Revolver is very interesting because the Beatles are now recording music that would be very difficult to perform live. And live performance is a huge part of the Beatles' engine. Eleanor Rigby. Tomorrow Never Knows. Tomorrow never knows.
我是《左轮手枪》的超级粉丝。《左轮手枪》非常有趣，因为披头士当时录制的音乐很难在现场进行表演。而现场演出是披头士乐队运转的巨大引擎。《埃莉诺·里比》（Eleanor Rigby）。《明日永远不知道》（Tomorrow Never Knows）。《明日永远不知道》。
Which is kind of playing things backwards. Yeah. These are all very difficult, if not impossible, now it could be done with modern technology, but they've become real recording geniuses and artists, and it's taking them in this other direction. So they finish Revolver, and enough time has gone by because I think people used to say, well, Sergeant Pepper or Abbey Road is their greatest, and those are obviously fantastic. But Revolver, I think if you asked one of the Beatles, they might have the greatest fondness for Revolver.
这有点像是倒放音乐。是的。这些都非常困难，如果不是不可能的话——虽然现在可以用现代技术做到——但他们已经成为了真正的录音天才和艺术家，这把他们带向了另一个方向。所以他们完成了《左轮手枪》，而且时间已经过去足够久了，因为我认为人们以前会说，嗯，《Sgt. Pepper》（佩珀中士）或《Abbey Road》（艾比路）是他们最伟大的专辑，那些显然也非常棒。但《左轮手枪》，我想如果你去问披头士乐队的某个人，他们可能对《左轮手枪》有着最深厚的感情。
And there's a kind of tension between now what they can do in a studio but not reproduce on a stage and the fact that they are starting to get a bit fed up with touring, because it's not only that they can't reproduce the musical effect. that they've got on Revolver on stage. It's also the fact that they can't barely hear themselves play. And they know that most people in their audience, because they're all screaming, they can't really hear them either. So that's frustrating. We just became like lip-sinking, you know, miming.
现在他们在录音室里能做到的事情与无法在舞台上重现的事情之间存在一种紧张关系，而且他们开始对巡演感到有点厌倦，因为不仅是他们无法在舞台上重现《左轮手枪》中的音乐效果，还有一个事实是他们几乎听不清自己的演奏。他们知道观众中的大多数人因为一直在尖叫，所以也听不清他们演奏。这让人感到沮丧。我们基本上就成了假唱，你知道的，对口型。
And we almost, sometimes things have breakdown and nobody had known. And so it wasn't doing the music any good. And then after they finish Revolver, they go on a world tour, and they go to Japan, and then they go to the Philippines, and they have a kind of awful run-in with Imelda Marcos, famous for her shoe collection. Yes. I was just there.
而且我们几乎，有时候事情出了状况也没有人知道。所以这对音乐没有任何好处。然后在他录完《左轮手枪》后，他们进行了世界巡演，去了日本，然后去了菲律宾，结果和伊梅尔达·马科斯（以鞋子收藏闻名）发生了相当糟糕的摩擦。是的。我刚刚去过那里。
I was just in the Philippines, and I went to the Manila Hotel, which is where the Beatles stayed. But you didn't turn down an invitation to tea with the head of the Philippines and getting trouble. I did, and I was bullied at the airport. Like the Beatles were. No, that was totally not the Beatles' fault.
我刚去过菲律宾，我去了马尼拉酒店，那是披头士住过的地方。但你没有拒绝邀请去和菲律宾元首喝茶并惹上麻烦。我拒绝了，而且我在机场遭到了霸凌。就像披头士当年那样。不，那绝对不是披头士的错。
The Marcos is announced that the Beatles will be appearing at the palace and having tea and then greeting a bunch of children, but no one asked the Beatles. And they're, as you guys would say, knackard. Yeah, they were knackard. They were knackard. They just wanted to use the loo and then take a lift. I'll never be invited again.
马科斯家族宣布披头士将出席总统府并喝茶，然后迎接一群孩子，但没有人问过披头士。而他们，正如你们所说，筋疲力尽。是的，他们累垮了。他们累坏了。他们只想上个厕所，然后乘电梯休息。我再也不会被邀请了。
But they were tired. They didn't want to do that. They said, no, we're not going to do that. And then, of course, the Marcos family said, this is a terrible snub. And they were in their hotel room watching this all unfold. And then they were hated. throughout the Philippines.
但他们累了。他们不想做那件事。他们说，不，我们不会那样做。然后，当然，马科斯家族说，这是一个可怕的怠慢。他们当时在酒店房间里看着这一切上演。然后他们受到了整个菲律宾的憎恨。
And there was a kind of real physical threat of danger. Yeah. And they kind of, you know, they made it out to their flight and it was all really traumatic. And they left the Philippines and said, we're never going back. And I don't think they ever did, actually. But kind of in a sense, worse was to come because we now come to the way that John Lennon's comments on Christianity was playing out in America. And there's kind of escalating outrage in the Bible Belt.
并且存在一种真正的身体威胁。是的。然后他们，你知道的，他们设法赶上了航班，这一切真的很痛苦。他们离开菲律宾后说，我们再也不回去了。我想他们确实再也没回去过。但从某种意义上说，更糟糕的事情还在后头，因为我们现在来看看约翰·列农关于基督教的言论在美国是如何发酵的。圣经带的愤怒情绪正在不断升级。
DJs there are inviting people to bring their records and their be. Beatles' wigs and to kind of burn them. Don't forget to take your beetle records and your beetle paraphernalia to any one of our 14 pickup points in Birmingham, Alabama. And lots of people are kind of carrying around placards saying, you know, Jesus died for your sins, John Lennon, and the Ku Klux Klan are getting in on the act. And it's a pretty menacing environment, isn't it? Yeah.
那里的DJ邀请人们带着他们的唱片和披头士假发去烧掉它们。别忘了把你的披头士唱片和披头士周边带到我们在阿拉巴马州伯明翰的 14 个接货点之一。许多人举着标语，上面写着“耶稣为你的罪而死，约翰·列农”，三K党也趁火打劫。这是一个相当具有威胁性的环境，对吧？是的。
And when the Beatles land in America and they are asked about this, you can see when John is speaking at the press conference. I mean, he looks traumatized. Yeah. Well, apparently, he's a tough guy, and he speaks his mind, and he's not afraid to back down, but this was traumatic for him, and he realizes that he's put the whole thing in jeopardy, and at one point, he cries. Apparently, he breaks down crying just with the group and Brian and says, I'll do what I have to do to fix this. And he does. He gives an apology. It's a bit of a non-apology apology. But I'm not saying that we're better or greater or comparing us with Jesus Christ as a person or God as a thing or whatever it is.
当披头士降落美国并被问及此事时，你可以看到约翰在记者会上发言时的样子。我的意思是，他看起来受了创伤。是的。嗯，显然，他是个硬汉，有话直说，也不怕退缩，但这对他来说是痛苦的，他意识到他把整件事置于危险之中，在某个时刻，他哭了。据说他在队员和布莱恩面前崩溃大哭了，并说我一定会做我必须做的事来弥补这一切。他确实做到了。他进行了道歉。这有点像是一次并非真正道歉的道歉。但并不是说我们比耶稣基督更好、更伟大，也不是把我们与作为个人的耶稣基督或作为事物的上帝相提并论，或者诸如此类的话。
You know, I just said what I said and it was wrong or was taken wrong and now it's all this. But he clarifies his remarks and of course people that don't like the Beatles won't be satisfied, but it feels like it's enough for them to get to move on. And so they decide after this that they have had enough of touring. And so from this point on, they essentially are going to be meeting in the studio and developing albums of increasing complexity, technological and musical. But there is also a sense, isn't there, I think, that what that embroilio in America in 1966 had kind of revealed was the scale of the cultural rupture that is going on in the 60s between an increasingly kind of countercultural take. on religion and the Vietnam War and a kind of host of issues and a kind of a conservatism that is still very much there. And there is a real kind of cultural divide starting to widen.
你知道，我只是说了我所说的话，那是错的，或者被误解了，现在闹成了这样。但他澄清了自己的言论，当然，不喜欢披头士的人不会满意，但感觉这已经足够让他们继续前进了。因此，在此之后，他们决定受够了巡演。所以从这一点开始，他们基本上将在录音室里碰面，并开发制作越来越复杂的专辑，无论是在技术上还是在音乐上。但与此同时，我认为，1966 年美国那场混乱在某种程度上揭示的是，20年代60年代正在发生的文化断层的规模——反主流文化对宗教和越南战争的看法与某种保守主义之间存在着真正的文化鸿沟，这种保守主义依然非常浓厚。一种真正的文化分化开始拉大。
And as you go from 1966 into 1967, this will become very apparent because 1967 will be famous for the Summer of Love. It is the Beatles who provide, in a sense, the soundtrack for that with two massive, massive kind of musical monuments. The first double A-side, Strawby Fields Forever, and Penny Lane. Penny Lane, there is a bar for showing photographs of every head he's had the pleasure to know. And all the people that come and go, stop and say hello. On the corner is a banker with a motor car The little children having him behind his back And the banker net wears a mac
当你从 1966 年走到 1967 年时，这将变得非常明显，因为 1967 年将因“爱之夏”而闻名。披头士乐队在某种程度上为这一切提供了配乐，他们推出了两首巨大无比的音乐里程碑。第一张双A面单曲，草莓地永远（Strawberry Fields Forever）和 Penny Lane（佩妮巷）。在佩妮巷，有一个理发店展示着他有幸认识的每一个头像的照片。所有来来往往的人，停下来打个招呼。转角处停着一辆汽车和一个银行家，小孩子们在他身后追逐，银行家穿着一件麦金托什雨衣。
In the pouring rain, very strange Penny Lane is in my ears and in my eyes And then it's important to remember that we're just two years away from Nixon being elected president. And what Nixon reveals and his campaign is that there is a huge part of the United States that isn't down. with the kids and wants no part of it and through the Beatles we're starting to see this showing up and we're going to see it very clearly in two years but it's one of the reasons they stop touring they can't hear themselves the technology for touring on the Beatles scale was terrible
在倾盆大雨中，非常奇怪。佩妮巷在我的耳边，在我的眼里。然后重要的是要记住，距离尼克松当选总统仅仅过去两年。尼克松和他的竞选活动所揭示的是，美国有很大一部分人不买账，不想参与其中，通过披头士乐队，我们开始看到这种现象显现出来，我们将在两年后非常清楚地看到这一点，但这也是他们停止巡演的原因之一，他们听不清自己的声音，当时披头士规模的巡演技术太糟糕了。
they're still using these relatively small Vox amps they when they play giant stadiums They're piping it through the public announce address system. So they can't hear themselves. People can't hear them. And I think, I mean, John Lennon always said they were a terrific live band and they got something from that. But now there's no communicating with an audience that size. There's no give and take. So they've got to move on.
他们仍然在使用这些相对较小的 Vox 音箱，当他们在巨大的体育场演奏时。他们通过公共广播系统进行扩音。所以他们听不到自己的声音。人们也听不到他们。而且我认为——我的意思是，约翰·列农总是说他们是一支极棒的现场乐队，他们从中获得了一些东西。但现在已经无法与那个规模的观众进行交流了。没有互动。所以他们必须继续前行。
They take a break after they stop touring. John goes off and makes how I won the war. That's where he starts wearing his round glasses. His, I guess, it was a government issue, granny glasses. And then Paul does the score for the family way, I think. Everyone takes a little bit of a breather. A little bit of a breather. And then they get back together.
他们停止巡演后休息了一段时间。约翰去拍了《我如何赢得战争》（How I Won the War）。这就是他开始戴圆形眼镜的地方。他的，我猜，那是政府发给的奶奶眼镜。然后保罗为《家族路》（The Family Way）配乐，我想。每个人都喘了口气。稍微喘了口气。然后他们重新聚在一起。
Paul has an idea and they start working on Sergeant Pepper. But you mentioned that they have this incredible single they put out, an A side and a B side, which is Strawberry Fields Forever. and then Penny Lane, they were meant to be part of the new album. But because of this demand that there always be new singles, two of the greatest songs the Beatles would ever make are put on an A and a B side and put out and now can't be on the album, which today people would say, well, that's silly, put it on the album too.
保罗有一个想法，他们开始制作《佩珀中士》。但你提到他们推出了这张不可思议的单曲，一张 A 面和一张 B 面，即《草莓地永远》和《佩妮巷》，它们本应是新专辑的一部分。但由于对源源不断的新单曲的需求，披头士创作的有史以来最伟大的两首歌被放在了 A 面和 B 面发行，现在无法收录在专辑里了，今天人们会说，这太傻了，也把它放进专辑里吧。
But they were very strict about that. You mentioned how Nixon in America is lurking in the wings, and it would be remiss of me at this point, not to ventriloquized Dominic, whose great point is that Sgt Pepper will be outsold by The Sound of Music in 1967. Penny Lane and Throbby Fields, which lots of critics have said is the kind of cultural pinnacle of post-war British achievement. I think without a doubt the greatest single The Beatles ever released. It's their first one for eons not to become number one. And it's kept off the top spot by Engelbert Humperdink.
但他们对此非常严格。你提到美国的尼克松潜伏在幕后，此时如果我不借多米尼克之口说出他的观点，那就太失职了——多米尼克的伟大观点是，《佩珀中士》在 1967 年的销量会被《音乐之声》（The Sound of Music）超过。《佩妮巷》和《草莓地》，许多评论家称之为战后英国成就的文化巅峰。我认为毫无疑问这是披头士发行过的最伟大的单曲。这是他们无数年来第一首未能成为冠军单曲的作品。而它被恩格尔伯特·汉姆珀丁克（Engelbert Humperdinck）挤下了榜首。
So they're not having it all their way, but it is a transcendent achievement, isn't it? And it takes them back to Liverpool. So both Penny Lane and Strawberry Fields locations in Liverpool. Yeah. I think Strawberry Fields Forever might be my favorite Beatles song. Penny Lane for me with the trumpet. They're both so incredible. They also show you both sides of this incredible songwriting team and they're perfection.
所以他们并没有事事如意，但这确实是一个超越性的成就，不是吗？它把他们带回了利物浦。所以《佩妮巷》和《草莓地》都是利物浦的地名。是的。我想《草莓地永远》可能是我最喜欢的披头士歌曲。对我来说是带有小号的《佩妮巷》。它们都太不可思议了。它们也向你展示了这个不可思议的词曲创作团队的两个方面，而且它们堪称完美。
with eyes closed Misunderstanding all you see It's getting hard to be someone But it all works out It doesn't matter much to me Let me take you down Because I'm going to Strawberry Fields
闭上眼睛，误解你所看到的一切，做人变得越来越难，但一切都会好起来的，这对我来说并不重要。让我带你下去，因为我要去草莓地。
Nothing is real, and nothing to get hung about. Stovary feels forever. And so this is how good the Beatles have become. You take these two songs, and you don't even put them on the watershed album, Sergeant Pepper. You take them off and issue them as a single. That would be unheard of today. I mean, the only track I think that transcends it is a day in the life, which is the last, song on Sergeant Pepper and perfectly fuses the best of John and Paul and is designed to be a
没有什么什么是真实的，没有什么值得纠结的。草莓地永远。这就是披头士变得多么优秀的地方。你拿出这两首歌，甚至不把它们放在里程碑式的专辑《佩珀中士》中。你把它们拿出来作为单曲发行。这在今天是闻所未闻的。我的意思是，我认为唯一超越它的曲目是《A Day in the Life》（生活中的一天），它是《佩珀中士》的最后一首歌，完美融合了约翰和保罗的最佳状态，旨在成为一种压倒性的交响乐体验。
kind of overwhelming symphonic experience. Here we are in Abbey Road. They invited, you know, vast orchestra to come in and play all kinds of mad tunes and, you know, crashes out and you're left with this incredible silence, which continues on the album. And it's all very groovy and it's all very countercultural. And you do get the sense with Sergeant Pepper that the Beatles are starting to, as the Queen put it, go a bit odd. So it's not just that the music is more radical and edgy and kind of exploring new ways of developing. But they're all, you know, the facial hair is starting to develop and the hair is getting even longer. Yes, I know that you and Dominic have beard obsessions and the beard start to show up. The mustache is.
我们现在在艾比路。他们邀请了庞大的管弦乐队进来演奏各种疯狂的曲调，伴随着巨响戛然而止，留下了这种不可思议的沉默，这种沉默在专辑中延续着。这一切都非常时髦，也非常反主流文化。而你确实能在《佩珀中士》中感受到，正如女王所说，披头士开始变得有点古怪了。所以不仅音乐更加激进、前卫，而且在探索新的发展方式。他们所有人，你知道的，面部毛发开始长出来，头发也变得更长了。是的，我知道你和多米尼克对胡子有执念，胡子开始出现了。小胡子。
and soon beards. But it's a concept album. It really isn't. Paul had this idea that it would be a whole album done by a fictional band called Sergeant Peppers, but they stick with that idea for maybe one or two songs. And then they give up, but it doesn't matter.
很快就是满脸大胡子了。但这是一张概念专辑。其实并不是。保罗有个想法，觉得应该是一整张由一个叫“佩珀中士”的虚构乐队制作的专辑，但他们这个想法只坚持了一两首歌。然后他们就放弃了，但这没关系。
It's really about that amazing cover. It's called the first concept album. It doesn't go anywhere. Mr. Kite, all my contributions are absolutely nothing to do with this idea of Sergeant Pepper and his band. But it works because we said it worked
这真的全靠那个惊艳的封面。它被称为第一张概念专辑。它并没有延续下去。风筝先生（Mr. Kite），我的所有贡献和“佩珀中士和他的乐队”这个概念完全没有关系。但它成功了，因为我们说它成功了，这就是它的呈现方式。
and that's how it appeared. They're dealing now with their work as real art. To own that album is to own a piece of art. And it's seen as exemplifying the Summer of Love and this radical developments that are taking place in San Francisco, particularly Hayd Ashbury, as well as in Carnaby Street and Swinging London. And there is a track on Sergeant Pepper called Lucian. the sky with diamonds, which people point out, well, the initials of that song, LSD.
他们现在把自己的作品当作真正的艺术来对待。拥有那张专辑就是拥有了一件艺术品。它被视为“爱之夏”的例证，以及在旧金山（特别是海特-阿什伯里）以及卡纳比街和摇摆伦敦正在发生的激进发展。在《佩珀中士》中有一首歌叫《带着钻石的天空中的露西》（Lucy in the Sky with Diamonds），人们指出，这首歌的首字母缩写就是 LSD。
And this is the time when the Beatles, even Paul, he'd been very reluctant to take it, starts taking it LSD. I mean, they always deny that it was, but it's kind of hovering in the atmosphere. And that sense of drugs as opening the mind, you know, you can tune in and discover new things about yourself. That is also part of the excitement for people who are listening to Sergeant Pepper of what is going on, isn't it? The sense that new opportunities are opening up. There's this new idea that drugs can provide all these positive benefits.
而正是这个时候，披头士，甚至是保罗——他以前非常抗拒服用它——也开始服用 LSD。我的意思是，他们总是否认这一点，但它就像某种氛围一样盘旋在空中。那种认为毒品可以开启心智的观念，你知道的，你可以调频并发现关于自己的新事物。这也是听众在收听《佩珀中士》时感受到的兴奋感的一部分，不是吗？那种新的机遇正在打开的感觉。出现了一种新观念，即毒品可以带来所有这些积极的好处。
And this is, you know, a number of years before we start losing people to drugs. And John tends to overdo things. So he goes... He's all in. He's all in on LSD to the point where he's positively green from it. I was aware of them smoking pot, and I wasn't aware that they did anything really serious. In fact, I was so innocent that I actually took John up into the roof when he was having an LSD trip and not knowing what it was. Paul takes LSD because John is off, you know, off his face and he wants to kind of, you know, accompany John in his, you know, this terrible kind of experience.
而这发生在我们在毒品中失去生命之前的几年。而且约翰往往会做得过火。所以他……他全情投入。他全力投入到 LSD 中，甚至到了脸色发青的地步。我知道他们在抽大麻，但我不知道他们做过什么真正严重的事。事实上，我当时是如此天真，以至于当约翰在经历一次 LSD 旅行却不知道那是什么时，我竟然把他带到了屋顶上。保罗服用 LSD 是因为约翰已经神志不清了，他想在约翰这种糟糕的体验中陪伴约翰。
I was finding kind of very touching, moving illustration of their. Yeah, he felt the need to, I've got to do this too, so that I can know what he knows, but he never goes as far as John. But this opens up a lot in their music. And of course, John is so influenced already by Alison Wonderland imagery. So that's the other thing, isn't it? That even as they are kind of pushing at the limits in a kind of Timothy Leary kind of way, They are still drawing on the traditions of their childhood.
我发现这是一种非常触动人心、感人至深的对他们……的诠释。是的，他觉得有必要这样做，我也必须这样做，这样我才能体会到他的感受，但他从未像约翰走得那么远。但这为他们的音乐打开了广阔的天地。当然，约翰已经深受《爱丽丝梦游仙境》意象的影响。所以这是另一回事，不是吗？即使他们以蒂莫西·Leary式的方式突破极限，他们仍然在汲取童年传统的养分。
So we meant Alice in Wonderland, but even Sergeant Pepper. I mean, they're kind of dressing up in Edwardian style uniforms and there's the fairground noises in the benefit of Mr. Kite, which was a kind of fairground poster. There's a kind of Edwardian vibe there, even as the hippies are crowding in. I have a theory that many artists get lost in the 60s because you start to think, if I think of it and I do it, it must be good. There are many terrible songs written in the 60s, and there are many terrible movies made in the 60s, especially in the later 60s. People can tend to lose their way because there's this concept that we just made it. It's wacky. It's what happened.
所以我们的意思是《爱丽丝梦游仙境》，甚至还有《佩珀中士》。我的意思是，他们穿上爱德华七世风格的制服，《平民凯特受益演出》（Being for the Benefit of Mr. Kite!）中有游乐场的噪音，那是一种游乐场海报的风格。那里有一种爱德华七世时期的氛围，尽管嬉皮士们正蜂拥而至。我有一个理论，许多艺术家在 20 世纪 60 年代迷失了自我，因为你开始觉得，如果我想到了并且我做了，那它一定就是好的。60 年代创作了许多糟糕的歌曲，60 年代拍了许多糟糕的电影，尤其是 60 年代后期。人们往往会迷失方向，因为存在这样一种观念：我们刚刚制作了它。这很古怪。这就是发生的事情。
It doesn't make sense, but it doesn't have to. I think the Beatles survive it really well because they're rooted in this discipline, the music hall, music structure, production, fine production. they're rooted in all these things that help give them ballast even though, yes, they're taking LSD, they've been smoking a lot of pot, they always have that ballast of there's work to be done
这没有意义，但它也不需要有意义。我认为披头士很好地挺过来了，因为他们根植于这种纪律、音乐厅、音乐结构、制作、优秀的制作中。他们根植于所有这些能够帮助他们保持平衡的事物中，尽管，是的，他们当时在吸食 LSD，抽了很多大麻，但他们始终拥有“还有工作要做而且必须做好”这一平衡。
and it needs to be good. And I think also they consistently have a sense of the ridiculous. They can recognize when people are making idiots of themselves. So it's interesting that George goes to San Francisco and he hangs out and hate Ashby and he wants to see the flower power revolution
而且我认为他们始终有一种荒诞感。他们能够认出什么时候有人在把自己当成傻瓜。所以有趣的是，乔治去了旧金山，他在海特-阿什伯里闲逛，他想见证花之力量革命，和嬉皮士之类的人混在一起。实际上他，你知道的，他认为这里有很多牺牲品，并决定这其实不适合他。我的意思是，我们去过的每个地方，人们都在微笑，你知道的，坐在草坪上喝茶，你知道的，音乐节之类的东西。我的意思是，你知道的，那个爱之夏。很多都是废话，真的。
and hang out with hippies and stuff. And actually he's, you know, he thinks quite a lot of casualties here and decides it's not really for him. I mean, everywhere we went, people were smiling and, you know, sitting on lawns, drinking tea, you know, festivals of music and stuff. I mean, you know, that's summer of love. A lot of that was bullshit, really.
这都是媒体在炒作。所以他想探索获得开悟的替代途径。凭借巨大的好运，他通过介绍认识了一个叫玛哈瑞西·马 महेश Yogi（玛哈瑞西·马赫什·瑜吉）的人，他刚刚出现在伦敦。乔治说服了其他披头士成员以及米克·贾格尔和玛丽安·费思富尔和玛哈瑞西一起坐火车去威尔士的班戈。那么你对玛哈瑞西有什么看法？嗯，我认为披头士是非常好奇的人，他们总是想前进到下一个水平并学习更多。所以当他们听到关于这个玛哈瑞西的事情时，他们想，让我们试试看，听听他怎么说。
It was all what the press were saying. And so he wants to explore alternative ways of attaining in light. And by a great good fortune, he is put in touch with a guy called the Maharishi, Maheshiyogi, who has just turned up in London. And George persuades the other Beatles and Mick Jagger and Marianne Faithful to get on a train with the Maharishi and go to Banga in Wales. So what's your take on the Maharishi? Well, I think the Beatles are very curious people. and they always want to advance to the next level and learn more. And so when they hear about this Maharishi, they think, let's give it a try, let's hear them out.
所以这就是去班戈的旅行的意义所在。这是一次逃离。这是一场盛会。是的。他们一起去了。当然，辛西娅错过了火车，这非常有象征意义。同样具有象征意义的是，当他们在班戈时，他们得到了一个可怕的消息，那就是布莱恩·埃普斯坦——他们的经理，那个曾塑造了他们的职业生涯并让他们步入正轨的人——在伦敦因吸毒过量去世了。
So that's what the trip, I think, to Bangor's about it. It's a getaway. It's a happening. Yeah. They all go together. Of course, Cynthia misses the train, which is very symbolic. And also symbolic is the fact that while they're in Bangor, they get terrible news, which is that Brian Epstein, their manager, the guy who would share. shaped their career and kind of kept them on track as died of an overdose back in London.
是的。就在他们听到消息后，有录像资料显示，他们走了出来，他们在威尔士，他们听了玛哈瑞西的讲座。他们得到了布莱恩去世的消息，在明亮的灯光和镜头前，你可以看到这段录像。他们完全惊呆了。嗯，我不知道该说什么，你知道的。我们刚刚听到，很难想出该说的话，但这真是一个美好的人，你知道的，这太可怕了。
Yeah. And there's footage right after they hear, they walk out, they're in Wales, they've listened to the Maharishi. They get the news that Brian's died and bright, bright lights and a camera, and you can watch this footage. They are completely traumatized. Well, I don't know what to say, you know. We've only just heard, and it's hard to think of things to say, but it was just a beautiful One fella, you know, and it's terrible.
你们现在有什么计划？嗯，我们还没有制定任何计划，你知道的。我的意思是，这刚刚发生，我们才刚听到，我们所有的……这简直太令人震惊了，因为我们当时正沉浸在这种寻找生命意义的事情中，而他就这样死了。后来，约翰说：“我知道我们完蛋了。”这个人把所有一切都维系在一起，而他走了。这尤其具有创伤性，我认为对约翰和保罗可能也是如此，因为他们在童年时都失去了生命中的关键人物。他们都失去了母亲。你从那段录像中可以看出他们惊呆了。记者问他们：“玛哈瑞西说了什么？”约翰的方式是，他基本上给了我们这些陈词滥调。
What are your plans now? Well, we haven't made any, you know. I mean, it's only just, we only just heard, all we. That was kind of stunning, because we were off on this sort of finding the meaning of life, and there he was dead. And much later, John said, I knew then we'd had it. This was the guy who kept everything together, and he's gone. And particularly traumatic, I think, for John and probably Paul, too, because they had both lost
而约翰在这个层面上，他的观点并不是说这是陈词滥调。我理解今天下午玛哈瑞西和你们所有人都进行了交谈。我能问问他给了你们什么建议吗？他告诉我们不要被悲伤压倒，无论我们对布莱恩有什么想法，都要保持快乐，因为我们对他的任何想法都会传送到他所在的地方。但你可以看出，约翰可能已经不是那种认为玛哈瑞西能取代他在生活中的布莱恩地位的人了。
key figures of their life as kids. They had lost their moms. You can see in that footage that they are dumbstruck. The interviewer says to them, what did the Maharishi say? And John's way, he basically gave us these platitudes.
我的意思是，你说过约翰最终会说这一切就此结束。中场休息后我们再深入探讨这一点。你们都看了时代巡回演唱会（The Eras Tour）。现在是时候走到后台了。在迪士尼+上观看《泰勒·斯威夫特：时代巡回演唱会终章》（Taylor Swift, The End of an Era），探索轰动全球的时代巡回演唱会背后的故事。这部富有启示性的纪录片系列揭开了泰勒生活的神秘面纱，当时她的巡回演唱会成为头条新闻，令全球粉丝为之狂热。在这场属于时代的流媒体活动中体验从未公开的镜头，
And John, at this level, his point isn't saying their platitudes. I understand that this afternoon Maharishi conferred with you all. Could I ask you what advice he offered you? He told us not to get overwhelmed by grief and to whatever thoughts we have of Brian
包括在温哥华的最后一场演出。《泰勒·斯威夫特：时代巡回演唱会终章》。星期五独家上线迪士尼+。大家好，欢迎回到《一切皆历史》，这是我们与柯南·奥布莱恩共同呈现的披头士主题狂欢节目。柯南，我们刚刚说到披头士因失去长期以来的经纪人布莱恩·埃普斯坦而饱受创伤，他们开始质问自己，未来会怎样？是的，他们现在正处于十字路口。有趣的是，他们过去可能总是对布莱恩的西装革履以及他的某些想法和概念有些反感。但当他离去时，我想他们大概才意识到他是多么紧密地把他们所有人维系在一起。你在前半场说过，披头士非常擅长避免陷入最终演变成灾难的疯狂、荒诞的旅程。但实际上，他们在布莱恩死后正是这么做的。因为保罗几乎出于本能地开始承担起经纪人的角色，他说：“为什么我们不进行一次酷炫的英国公路旅行呢？这可以是一次神奇的神秘之旅（Magical Mystery Tour）。”再次，这结合了传统英国文化的想法——坐上大巴去黑潭或类似的地方——以及人们声称自己是海象之类的东西。
to keep them happy because any thoughts we have of him will travel to him wherever he is. But you can see that already John is not the kind of person probably who's going to think that the Maharishi is the guy to replace Brian in his life.
所以这是迷幻风格与海边风情的融合，但这是一场彻头彻尾的灾难。嗯，我认为问题之一在于披头士非常自信，因为当他们不得不尝试事情并做事时，他们非常非常有能力。他们没有经历过失败，但现在他们把这种自信延伸到了导演和制作一部连贯的电影上——这能有多难？我想保罗趴在地板上，拿着一张巨大的纸画了一个圆。然后他创作电影的方式，我想，就是把圆划成不同部分并画上箭头。我的意思是，我喜欢它。是的，他会说，里面有很棒的时刻。他会说，看，它是用彩色拍摄的。BBC 在节礼日播出了它，而且是以黑白形式在小屏幕上播出的。
I mean, you said that John will ultimately say this is where it all ends. Let's explore that a bit further after a break. You all saw the heiress tour. Now it's time to go backstage. Discover the story behind the phenomenal heiress tour in Taylor Swift, The End of an Era, on Disney Plus. This illuminating docu-series lifts the curtain on Taylor's life as her tour made headlines and thrilled fans around the world. Experience never-before-seen
那本来不是它应该被观看的方式。如果你真的仔细看，它还是禁得起推敲的。里面有很多不错的东西。但在当时，它被视为一场灾难。它遭到评论家的抨击。人们认为披头士疯了。这对他们来说是又一个巨大的坎坷。但我不该这么说。
footage in this streaming event for the eras, including the final show in Vancouver. Taylor Swift, the end of an era. Streaming Friday only on Disney Plus. Hello, everyone, and welcome back to the rest of history, our Beatles-themed extravaganza with Conan O'Brien and Conan. We left the Beatles traumatized by the loss of Brian Epstein, their manager for so long, and kind of asking themselves, well, what does the future hold? Yeah, they're at a crossroads now. And it's funny there's always been probably some chafing against Brian.
按他们的风格来说，这并不是致命的。而且我认为《我是海象》（I Am the Walrus）的那段序列——约翰最伟大的歌曲之一——最终以李尔王在背景中喃喃自语告终。背景里所有人都在发出咕咕咕的怪声。我认为这是他们最伟大的时刻之一。我喜欢他们在《神奇神秘之旅》中为《我是海象》制作的录像带。他们似乎身处某种军事基地。看起来他们只花了大约七分钟用一架钢琴、即兴的滑稽面具和根本没有用胶水粘贴的光头假发来布置场景。
in his suits and they had probably at times chafed, you know, at some of his ideas and concepts. But then when he's gone, I think they probably realized how much he had held them all together. And you said in the first half that the Beatles are very good at not going off on kind of mad, lunatic journeys that turn out to be disasters. But actually, that is what they do in the wake of Brian's death. Because Paul, who almost by default, is kind of stepping up to play the managerial role, says, well, why don't we go on a kind of groovy road trip around Britain? It could be a magical mystery tour. And again, it's this kind of idea of traditional British culture that you get on a bus and you go off to Blackpool or something, combined with people claiming to be walruses and such like.
但这很有趣，是他们在享受乐趣、胡闹，这种情绪很有感染力。所以这种胡闹，你知道的，这从一开始就是披头士的基础，一直追溯到采石工人乐队（The Quarrymen）那段日子。稍微新鲜一点的是那种非常认真地前往喜马拉雅山寻求开悟的想法，这随后发生在 1968 年初，玛哈瑞西重新出现，因为他在瑞诗凯诗（Rishikesh）有一个很大的修行地。他说，来吧，你知道的，来我脚下坐坐，学习智慧。几年前玛哈瑞西去世时，有人写了一篇非常深思熟虑的文章，说他是披头士故事中的重要部分，因为在布莱恩死后，他们都精疲力竭，精神涣散，生活陷入混乱，而对于地球上最大的明星来说，他们做了一件很不寻常的事。他们去了一个隐修处。他们没有带电吉他，而是带了木吉他，我想是马丁吉他，他们坐在一起，周围安静平和，除了念经什么也没有做。
So it's a kind of fusion of the psychedelic and the kind of seaside, but it's an absolute disaster. Well, I think one of the problems is that the Beatles are very confident people because when they've had to try things and do things, they're very. extremely highly competent. They haven't had a failure, but now they extend it to how hard could it be to direct and make a cohesive film. And I think Paul gets on the floor and he has a giant sheet of paper and he draws a circle. And then his way of creating the movie is, I think, to just section off parts of the circle and arrows. I mean, I like it. Yeah, he would say, it has great moments in it. He would say, look, it was shot in color. It was aired by the BBC on Boxing Day, and in black and white, on little screens.
他们开始写歌，基本上白色专辑的大部分都是在那段时期创作的，就像其他事情一样，他们抓住一个契机，并将其转化为对他们有利的结果。所以即使他们没有找到开悟和灵性，他们也写了大量的歌曲，否则他们可能写不出来。嗯，他们的反应各有不同，不是吗？林戈带了一大堆烤豆去。
That's not the way it was meant to be seen. And it holds up if you really look at it. And there are a bunch of good things in it. But at the time, it's seen as a disaster. It gets panned by the critics. People think the Beatles have lost their minds. It's another big bump in the road for them. But I shouldn't say that.
他的手提箱里装满了亨氏烤豆，因为他的胃，他担心自己的胃。保罗，我的意思是，他有点适应，又有点不太适应。约翰则大发雷霆。
In their way, terminal. Not at all. And I think the I Am A Waris sequence, one of John's great songs, kind of ends up with King Lear muttering in the background. They're all go-goo-goo-go-go-go-go-go-go-doing in the background. And it's, I think, one of their great moments. I love the video they made in Magical Mystery Tour for I Am the Wallace. They seem to be at some kind of military complex. And it looks like they spent all of seven minutes setting up the scene with a piano and impromptu goofy masks and bald cap wigs that are just applied with no glue.
我觉得，你知道的，他写了一篇对玛哈瑞西的猛烈批判，他给这首歌起名为《Sexy Sadie》（性感萨迪），因为他担心玛哈瑞西会对他太生气或者别的什么。对乔治来说，印度灵性为他打开了整扇整扇的门户，他走了进去，再也没有出来。我的意思是，这对她来说是一次巨大的、巨大的经历，一次改变人生的经历。是的。是的，很多人不知道，《性感萨迪》最初的名字。
But it's fun and it's them having fun and goofing around, which is infectious. So the goofing around has, you know, that's been fundamental to the Beatles right from the very beginning, you know, right back to the days of the quarry. or whatever. What is slightly newer is the idea of very earnestly going off and getting enlightenment in the Himalayas, which is what then happens early in 1968, and the Maharishi reappears because he's got a kind of a big place out in Rishikesh. And he says, come on, you know, come on out and sit at my feet, learn wisdom. When the Maharishi died several years ago, someone wrote a really thoughtful piece which said he's an important part of the Beatle story because after Brian's death, they've all had it, they're fraying, their lives are
是《玛哈瑞西》。他们把它写成歌，几乎就像是律师出面说：“你们必须改名。有你们好受的。”是的，它，最初是《玛哈瑞西，有你好受的》（Maharishi, you'll get yours yet），然后是其他披头士成员说：“想想别的名字吧。”是的，他不想看起来像个被当成傻瓜的人，所以他非常生气并彻底拒绝了它。这又是那个时期涌现的众多歌曲之一。正如你所说，它收录在《白色专辑》（White Album）中。我想关于《白色专辑》有两点要说。首先，它是白色的。我的意思是，它其实不叫《白色专辑》，对吧？
chaotic, and they do a very unusual thing for the biggest stars on Earth. They go to a retreat. They don't bring electric guitars, they bring these acoustic guitars, I think these Martin guitars, and they sit around, and there's quiet and peace, and there's nothing to do except chant. and they start writing songs and essentially most of the white album was written during that period like anything else they take a moment
它叫《The Beatles》（披头士乐队），但它与《佩珀中士》的艳丽色彩形成了如此刻意的对比，就是这张白色的专辑。另一件事是它是一张双专辑，因为他们觉得有太多想放进去的歌。我知道乔治·马丁后来对此感到后悔。你是怎么想的？你认为它应该只是一张精彩的单专辑吗？还是说你有空间留给《革命第9号》（Revolution 9）？
and they make it work to their advantage so even though they didn't find enlightenment and spirituality they wrote a ton of songs they might not have written otherwise well they kind of respond in different ways don't they say Ringo has gone out with baked beans
我说，让披头士做披头士吧。所以我知道乔治·马丁认为，哦，它应该只是一张制作完美的专辑，而不是双专辑，但我站在保罗这边。他在精选集里说过。他说，你知道，人们说也许它可以是这个或者可以是那个。也许里面有些歌。
he has a suitcase filled with Heinz baked beans because of his stomach he's worried about his stomach yeah Paul is I mean he's kind of to it and kind of not really. John has a massive bust-up.
太多了。他说，哦，得了吧，这是披头士。这是《白色专辑》。你知道，我不太买账那种说法。你知道，也许里面有太多那种东西？你什么意思？这很棒。它卖爆了。
I feel, you know, and he writes an excoriation of the Maharishi, which he titles Sexy Sadie, because he's worried about, you know, whether the Maharishi will be too cross with him or whatever. For George, Indian spirituality opens up entire, you know, portals through which he goes and will never come back. I mean, it's a massive, massive experience for him, a life-changing experience. Yeah. Yeah, a lot of people don't know, sexy Sadie, the original title.
这就是该死的披头士。这张专辑怎么了？披头士体内依然有那么多伟大的歌曲，尤其是保罗，因为到这个时候，约翰开始对作为披头士成员的身份越来越幻灭。这在某种程度上是由几件事推动的。一是开始严重接触海洛因，
was Maharishi. They made it a song, it's almost as if lawyers showed up and said, you have to change that. You'll get yours yet. Yeah, it was, originally it was Maharishi, you'll get yours yet, and it was the other Beatles saying, let's think of another title. Yeah, he didn't want to look like anyone had made a fool of him, so he's very angry and rejects it completely. Yet another of the many songs that emerges from that period. And as you say, it goes on to the White album. And I suppose two things to say about the White album. First is, it's white. I mean, it's not actually called the white album, is it?
这显然对创造力是个不小的拖累。但另一件事是他的生活中出现了一个新女人，不是吗？他曾娶了辛西娅，但到了 1968 年，已经不再是了。是的，约翰遇到了这位艺术家小野洋子，他迷恋上了她，这显然——许多人说，正是这件事最终导致了披头士的解散，但我认为这不是真的。人们总是习惯为一件无论如何都会发生的事寻找替罪羊。所以，不，我不认为是洋子解散了披头士。她确实在某些录音过程中造成了紧张气氛。所以其实我曾待在一个袋子里。伦敦的泰特现代美术馆在两三年前办过一个洋子艺术展。
It's called the Beatles, but it's such a deliberate contrast with the kind of technicolor of Sergeant Pepper, just this white album. And the other thing is that it's a double album, because they kind of feel we've got so many songs we want to put it all on. I know that George Martin later regretted that. What do you think? Do you think it should have been just a brilliant single album? Or do you have room for Revolution 9?
有一个钻进袋子里的机会，我们就钻进袋子里搞了一场行为艺术。好吧。我可不想被你比下去。我和洋子一起待在袋子里过。洋子来参加节目，用一个袋子给了我一个惊喜，她以为我会太拘谨而不敢和她一起进去。但当然，作为一个十足的戏精，我一口答应了，我们两个都钻进了袋子。而且你个子很高？袋子装得下你吗？装得下。那是个特大号的袋子。我的袋子尺码是 XXL。但我跟洋子一起进了袋子里，然后我们在里面，现场有录音室观众，她问：“我们现在做什么？”她说：“好吧，就这样。现在我们从袋子里出来进广告。”我说：“不，洋子。我们得做点什么，因为这是喜剧规则。”所以我开始
I say, let the Beatles be the Beatles. And so I know George Martin thought, oh, it should just be one perfectly produced album, not a double album, but I'm on the Paul side of that. He says this in the anthology. He says, you know, people say maybe it could have been this or could have been that. And maybe there's songs in there.
我说，就让披头士做回披头士吧。我知道乔治·马丁觉得，哦，它应该是一张制作完美的专辑，而不是双专辑，但我是站在保罗这边的。他在《精选集》里也这么说过。他说，你知道，人们说也许它可以是这样，也许它可以是那样。也许里面有些歌。
There are too many. And he said, oh, come on, it's the Beatles. It's the white album. You know, I'm not a great one for that. You know, maybe it was too many of that. What do you mean? It was great. It's sold.
歌太多了。他说，得了吧，这是披头士。这是白色专辑。你知道，我不太买账。你知道，也许里面的东西太多了。你什么意思？它很棒。它卖得很好。
It's the bloody Beatles. Why is the album shut up? The Beatles still have so many great songs left in them, and particularly, I guess, Paul does, because by this point, John is starting to become increasingly disenchanted with his identity as a beetle. And it's kind of fueled, I guess, by a couple of things. One is that he's starting to get seriously into heroin,
这是该死的披头士。专辑怎么了？披头士身上仍然有很多伟大的歌曲，尤其是保罗，因为到这个时候，约翰开始对自己的披头士身份越来越幻灭。我想，这主要是由几件事引发的。首先是他开始严重吸食海洛因，
which is obviously quite a drag on one's creativity. But the other thing is that he's got a new woman. in his life, hasn't he? So he was married to Cynthia, but by 1968, no longer. Yeah, John has met this artist, Yoko Ono, and he's infatuated with her, and this is, obviously, many people say, well, this is what ended up breaking up the Beatles, but I think that's not true. People always want to blame somebody for something that I think would have happened anyway. And so, no, I don't think Yoko broke up the Beatles. She certainly creates strain in some of the recording sessions. So I've actually been in a bag. The Tate, modern, here in London, did a show
这显然对一个人的创造力是个相当大的拖累。但另一件事是，他的生活中出现了一个新女人，不是吗？他以前娶了辛西娅，但到1968年就不再在一起了。是的，约翰遇到了这位艺术家小野洋子，他为她神魂颠倒，这显然让很多人说，好吧，这就是最终导致披头士解散的原因，但我认为这不是真的。人们总是想把本无论如何都会发生的事情归咎于某个人。所以，不，我不认为洋子解散了披头士。她在一些录音期间确实造成了紧张气氛。所以其实我曾进过一个袋子里。伦敦的泰特现代美术馆在两三年前办过一个
of Yoko's art two or three years ago. There's an opportunity to get in a bag and we went in a bag and did a happening. Okay. I hate to top you. I've been in a bag with Yoko. Yoko came on the show and she surprised me with a bag and she thought that I'd be too uptight to get into it with her. But of course, being a terrible ham, I said absolutely we both got in the bag. And you're quite tall? Was the bank big enough to contain you? It was big enough. It was an extra large bag. I take an XXL in the bag. But I got into the bag with Yoko and then we were inside and there's a live studio audience and she said, what do we do now? She said, well, that's it. Now we just get out of the bag and go to commercial and I said, no, Yoko. We have to do something because that's the comedy rule. So I start
洋子艺术展。有一个钻进袋子里的机会，我们就钻进袋子里搞了一场行为艺术。好吧。我不忍心压过你。我和洋子一起进过袋子。洋子上了节目，用一个袋子给了我一个惊喜，她以为我会太拘谨而不敢跟她一起进去。但当然，作为一个糟糕的爱现鬼，我说绝对可以，我们俩都钻进了袋子。而且你挺高的？那个袋子大到能容纳你吗？大到可以。那是一个特大号的袋子。我进袋子要穿特大码（XXL）。但我跟洋子一起进了袋子，然后我们在里面，现场有演播室观众，她说，我们现在做什么？她说，好了，就这样。现在我们只要从袋子里出来进广告就行了，我说，不，洋子。我们必须做点什么，因为那是喜剧的规则。所以我开始
handing my clothes out of the bag. And then we emerged from the bag. I didn't take everything off. but I took, I think her, I think I took an article of her clothing and put it on, which looked absurd. Because Yoko had a thing where people would cut her clothing off, didn't she? I mean, it's quite something to have been in a bag with Yoko. I mean, do you feel one of the great moments for your life? It's the greatest moment of my life, and I have been at the birth of both of my children. So I'm a sociopath. You're a fan of Yoko's art.
把衣服从袋子里拿出来。然后我们从袋子里钻了出来。我没有把所有的衣服都脱掉，但我拿了，我想是她的，我想我拿了她的一件衣服穿上，看起来荒谬绝伦。因为小野洋子有一种习惯，让人把她的衣服剪碎，不是吗？我的意思是，和洋子一起待在一个袋子里，这可真不简单。我是说，你觉得这是你生命中最伟大的时刻之一吗？这是我生命中最伟大的时刻，而我曾经历过我两个孩子的出生。所以我是个反社会人格者。你是洋子艺术的粉丝。
Yeah. The saddest thing to me about this period are the clips I see where you can tell John is impaired, he's on heroin, or trying to come off heroin, and it makes me sad. The kind of being, I think, a kind of gentleman's agreement among the police that it was fine to arrest the Rolling Stones for drug offenses, but you leave the Beatles alone. That sense is starting to fade by now, and John and Yoko are arrested, and George is arrested. So there's a sense that the Beatles are becoming fair game now. There was a hierarchy in the pop world.
对。这一时期最让我难过的事，是我看到的一些视频片段：你能看出约翰状态不佳，他吸了海洛因，或者正试图戒毒，这让我很难过。我觉得，警方当时似乎有一种“君绅协定”：逮捕滚石乐队（Rolling Stones）的毒品犯罪是没问题的，但你们得离披头士（Beatles）远点。这种默契现在开始逐渐消退了，约翰和洋子被捕了，乔治也被捕了。所以有一种感觉，披头士现在成了可以随意攻击的目标。流行乐坛曾存在一个等级秩序。
Yeah. Beatles are on top, then the Rolling Stones, then the Who, kinks, way at the bottom, Hermann's Hermits. But now things are changing. You can arrest a beetle. You can arrest a beetle and charge them. So Paul, meanwhile, he is still very keen on being a beetle, keeping the Beatles on track. And his response to John's breakup with Cynthia is to drive down to Weybridge from London, to see Cynthia and John and Cynthia's son Julian
对。披头士高居榜首，然后是滚石乐队，然后是奇想乐队（The Who）、雷蒙斯乐队（Kinks），垫底的是赫尔曼的隐士乐队（Hermann's Hermits）。但现在情况变了。你可以逮捕一个“甲壳虫”。你可以逮捕一个甲壳虫成员并起诉他们。与此同时，保罗仍然非常热衷于当一个甲壳虫，让披头士保持正轨。他对约翰与辛西亚分手的反应是，从伦敦开车赶往韦布里奇，去看望辛西亚、约翰以及辛西亚的儿子朱利安。
and he writes one of the great Beatles singles. Hey Jude. They play it live on David Frost Show and that's their kind of first live performance for a very long while. It's my pleasure to introduce now in their first live appearance for goodness knows how long in front of an audience, The Beatles. Hey Jude, don't make it do.
他创作了披头士最伟大的单曲之一。《Hey Jude》。他们在大卫·弗罗斯特秀（David Frost Show）上进行现场表演，这是他们很长一段时间以来的首次某种现场演出。我很荣幸现在能隆重介绍，在不知多久以来面对观众的首次现场演出中登场的——披头士乐队。《Hey Jude》，别难过。
Take a sad song and make it better Remember to let her into your heart Then you can start to make it better Hate you Don't be afraid And then you were made to go out and get her. The minute you let her under your skin, then you begin to make it better.
带着一首悲伤的歌，把它唱得更好。记得让她走进你的心，然后你就可以开始把它变得更好。恨你，别害怕。然后你注定要走出去寻找她。一旦你让她深入你的皮肤，你就会开始把事情变好。
And also it's inordinately long, isn't it? So that's another kind of Beatles first. It breaks all these rules. No track has been that long. And at the time, someone said by that point, people thought well the Beatles have had it and then Hey Jude comes out and it's a massive massive hit and there's this amazing account of how Paul has the the tapes and he's kind of driving through the English countryside and they're going back to London they want to have
而且这首歌出奇的长，对吧？所以这也是披头士的又一个“第一次”。它打破了所有的这些规则。没有哪首曲子曾有这么长。当时，有人说，到那个时候，人们认为披头士已经完蛋了，然后《Hey Jude》问世了，它成了一首超级无敌的大热单曲。这里还有一个精彩的记录：保罗拿着磁带，开车穿过英格兰乡村，他们正要回伦敦，想去
you know take a break and they arrive in this picture perfect village and there's a pub and the pub is open and Paul goes in there and he plays hey Jude on the piano for people there and then he plays the track and people will always remember it. Yeah, it's one of the kind of examples of Beatles magic that you're just sitting in a pub and suddenly Paul McCartney walks in and plays Hey Jude for you. That sense that that magic is still there is obviously a kind of powerful motivator for Paul,
你知道的，休息一下，结果他们驶入了一个风景如画的村庄，那里有一家酒吧，酒吧开着门，保罗走进去，为那里的人们在钢琴上弹奏了《Hey Jude》，然后他播放了这首曲子，人们将永远铭记这一刻。是的，这是披头士魔力的典型例子之一：你正坐在一家酒吧里，突然保罗·麦卡特尼走进来为你弹奏《Hey Jude》。这种魔力依然存在的感觉得对保罗来说显然是一个强有力的动力，
but also for the other Beatles as well. And so they are prepared to listen to him when he proposes that they get back. Yeah. That they get back to kind of be, you know, doing live shows, the footage that got taken. of those sessions, which were kind of often seen as being very difficult and troubled. Peter Jackson kind of took the footage, didn't he, and made it into this incredible film
对其他披头士成员来说也是如此。因此，当他提议他们重新聚在一起时，他们愿意听取他的意见。是的。他们重新聚在一起，你知道的，进行现场演出，那些拍摄下来的花絮片段，这些录音过程通常被认为非常艰难和充满波折。彼得·杰克逊（Peter Jackson）把这些素材剪辑到了一起，不是吗，把它拍成了一部不可思议的电影，
where you can actually witness the process of songs being made. I mean, a lot of things I loved about Get Back. Just, I'm a geek, so getting to see all the equipment, how it really worked is fascinating. But basically, the greatest thing is seeing these guys together. and they're still making each other laugh. You get glimpses of the process. There are so many bits in it I loved. But I love the bit where, say, Paul by now is with Linda,
在片中你可以亲眼见证歌曲创作的过程。我是说，《Get Back》里有很多我喜欢的东西。简单来说，我是个极客，所以能看到所有的设备，看到它们是如何真正运作的，这太迷人了。但基本上，最棒的事情是看到这群家伙聚在一起，他们仍然在逗彼此笑。你可以一窥创作过程。里面有太多我喜欢的片段了。但我最喜欢的一个片段是，比如说，保罗这时已经和琳达在一起了，
who he will end up marrying. The most eligible bachelor in the world will get hitched to Linda. And Linda and Yoko were talking, and in the background, Paul is composing, get back. And it's like kind of watching, I don't know, Michelangelo think, oh, I don't know, should I have Adam and God and their fingers tight? Maybe, I don't know.
他最终将和琳达结婚。世界上最抢手的单身汉将迎娶琳达。琳达和洋子在交谈，而在背景里，保罗正在创作《Get Back》。这感觉就像是在看，我不知道，米开朗琪罗在想，哦，我不知道，我是不是该把亚当和上帝的手指紧紧相连？也许吧，我不知道。
He's in the background, yeah. It's so brilliant. But also, it's the fact that all of them looks so cool. I mean, George, George, just looks brilliantly cool in it. They're also just little fun things. I don't know what time of day it is, but Mao will say, does anyone want anything, and they'll all want some wine or beer? Cup of tea.
他在背景里，对。太精彩了。而且，事实上，他们所有人都看起来太酷了。我是说，乔治，乔治在里面看起来酷极了。里面还有很多有趣的小细节。我不知道当时是什么时间，但毛（Mao）会说，有人想要点什么吗，然后他们都会想要点红酒或啤酒？一杯茶。
Yeah, there's always a lot of toast. You're like, this is the biggest band in the world, and they've got, you know, there's not a bowl of cocaine, it's toast. It's all very British. Although you can see that John is really not well. Of the four of them, John is the one who's most kind of faded at that point. Although they were very keen to have a kind of spectacular climax to this process of filming. And so there was talk about doing them on a cruise ship or doing it in a Roman amphitheater in Africa.
对，总是有很多吐司。你会想，这是世界上最伟大的乐队，而他们有的，你知道的，不是一碗可卡因，而是吐司。这一切都非常英国风。尽管你能看出约翰真的状态不佳。在这四个人中，约翰是当时最显疲态的一个。尽管他们非常渴望为这个拍摄过程带来一个壮观的高潮，所以曾讨论过在一艘游轮上演出，或者在非洲的一个古罗马圆形剧场演出。
But then they haven't really got the energy for any of this. And so they decide that they will have a rooftop concert on the Apple building in Saville Row. But there's Heming and Hawing up until the moment. This is where Peter Jackson's documentary is so great. he lets you know that they're still in a back room as the equipment's all set up and they're ready to go on the rooftop, they're still deciding whether or not
但后来他们实在没有精力去搞这些了。于是他们决定在塞维尔街（Saville Row）的苹果大楼（Apple building）屋顶上办一场演唱会。但直到最后一刻，他们都还在犹豫不决。这就是彼得·杰克逊的纪录片如此棒的地方：他让你看到，当所有设备都安装好、他们准备上屋顶时，他们其实还在后台房间里，依然在决定到底
they're going to come out. Yeah. Because at this point, they have so many wounds from traveling and knowing what the spectacle was all about. They've been just living in a hobbit hole, engineering these great sounds. Why go out there and expose ourselves?
要不要出去。对。因为此时此刻，他们在巡演中受了太多伤，也深知那种大场面究竟是怎么回事。他们一直像住在霍比特洞里一样，潜心研制这些美妙的声音。为什么要走出去把自己暴露在聚光灯下？
So it's amazing when they come out. Don't let me down. Don't let me down Don't let me down Don't let me down Don't let me die Nobody ever loved me like she does Ooh she does
所以当他们走出来时，真是太棒了。别让我失望。别让我失望。别让我失望。别让我失望。别让我死。从来没有人像她那样爱过我。哦，她爱过。
Yes she does And if somebody love me like she does, who she does? Yes, she does. Don't let me down. Don't let me down. Don't let me down. Don't let me down.
是的，她爱过。如果有人像她那样爱我，哦，她爱过？是的，她爱过。别让我失望。别让我失望。别让我失望。别让我失望。
Don't let me down. I'm in love. All of London gathers on the streets below and then the police come and stop the farm and actually that's kind of a perfect way for the film to end. Yeah, there was some disappointment. I think Paul really wanted them or George or Ringo. They really wanted the police to grab them
别让我失望。我恋爱了。整个伦敦的人都聚集在下方的街道上，然后警察赶来制止了这场演出，实际上，这可以说是电影完美的结局。是的，多少有点遗憾。我想保罗真的很希望警察——或者乔治、林戈——他们真的很希望警察能冲上去，
and physically roll them off because that would be a better end to the film. There's a part in it that's very sad to me which is they're all, they're sitting in four chairs and Peter Sellers comes in.
把他们硬生生地拽下来，因为那样作为电影的结局会更好。片中有一个部分让我觉得非常难过，那就是他们全都坐在四把椅子上，彼得·塞勒斯（Peter Sellers）走了进来。
Do you remember this part? Peter Sellers comes in and says, hello, fellas. Five years before they had met Peter Sellers and it was one of the biggest thrills of their life and they're young and they're excited. Now it's the number of years later
你还记得这一段吗？彼得·塞勒斯走进来，说道：“嗨，伙计们。”五年前，他们曾见过彼得·塞勒斯，那是他们生命中最激动人心的时刻之一，那时他们年轻，充满兴奋。而现在，又是好几年过去了，
and John's on heroin and they're tired. Yeah. And they're all sitting in four chairs is like mannequins. For some reason, that segment, and I think John makes a joke about watch out for the needles on the floor. He makes a heroin joke to Peter Sellers.
约翰吸了海洛因，他们累了。是的。他们都像人体模特一样坐在四把椅子上。出于某种原因，那个片段——而且我想约翰还开玩笑说“小心地上的针头”。他对彼得·塞勒斯开了个海洛因的玩笑。
And it's just starting to, the milk is starting to curdle a little. Yeah, and adding to the stress is the fact that they're now supposed to be a business. So I mentioned the Apple Building in Saville, Ray. This is the headquarters for a groovy new company that the Beatles have set up as a kind of tax dodge. And they've set it up in a very 1960s, hope that you get rid of the pigs and the man and the capitalists and just let groovy people like Magic Alex, a Greek engineer, come up with lunatic schemes and everything will be great. He can make a studio that levitate.
一切开始变味了，牛奶开始有点变质了。是的，雪上加霜的是，他们现在还非得像个真正的企业在运作。所以我提到了塞维尔街的苹果大楼。这是披头士为了避税而建立的一家酷炫新公司的总部。他们以一种非常1960年代的方式建立它：希望摆脱那些条条框框、官僚和资本家，只让像“神奇亚历克斯”（Magic Alex，一个希腊工程师）这样的酷人想出各种疯狂的计划，一切就会变得美好。他能建造一个会悬浮的录音室。
Hello, I'm Alexis from Apple Electronics. I would like to say hello to all my brothers around the world and to all the girls around the world and to all the electronic people around the world. Apple basically, they're saying, come in and rip us off. And so loads of people do come and rip them off. And so they've got money problems as well as all the other issues that are going on. Tensions over music, tensions over drugs, tension over, you know, their respective spouses. And now money. And money is probably the kind of the biggest thing.
你好，我是来自苹果电子（Apple Electronics）的亚历克西斯。我想向全世界的兄弟们、全世界的女孩们以及全世界所有电子界的人士问好。苹果公司基本上就是在大喊：快来坑我们吧。于是大批的人真的跑来坑他们。所以除了其他各种问题，他们现在还有了财务问题。音乐上的摩擦、毒品上的摩擦、关于各自伴侣的摩擦。现在又多了钱的问题。而钱可能成了最大的问题。
Yeah. Because Paul wants his father-in-law, so Linda's father, to run their finances for them. and the other three want a guy called Alan Klein. I mean, he seems quite a kind of New York figure, quite a New York character. Yeah, I think thug-ish is one word people might use. I think the Rolling Stones felt they had had a good experience with him. John hears about this tough guy who can come in and get you a better royalty rate. He's all down.
对。因为保罗希望他的岳父——也就是琳达的父亲——来为他们管理财务。而其他三人则想要一个叫艾伦·克莱恩（Alan Klein）的人。我的意思是，他看起来挺有纽约客的做派，是个挺典型的纽约人物。对，我想“像个暴徒”可能是人们会用的一个词吧。我觉得滚石乐队觉得跟他的合作体验挺好。约翰听说有这么个硬汉能进来帮你争取到更好的版税分成，他完全赞同。
It's actually in Get Back. John's had a meeting with him, and he goes and he says to George, I mean, I think he knows me as well as you do, or better, George. I mean, can you imagine George hearing this? He's been with John since 1957, 58, and now John's had one meeting. Yeah, when I wonder, George walks out. I'll see you in the clubs.
这其实在《Get Back》里就有。约翰和他开过会，然后他走过去对乔治说，我的意思是，我觉得他了解我跟你一样深，甚至比你更了解我，乔治。我的意思是，你能想象乔治听到这话时的感受吗？他从1957、1958年就一直跟约翰在一起了，而现在约翰只开了一次会。是的，你可以想象，乔治气冲冲地走了出去。“俱乐部见。”
Yeah. And he walks out. They get him back in. But there's a lot of bad feeling now. And again, this is all part and parcel of magical mystery tour. Hey, how hard it could it be to make a movie? You know, the Apple boutique, how hard could it be to make a shop and sell movie clothes? Apple music, how hard could it be to make a shop and sell movie clothes?
对，他走了出去。他们又把他劝了回来。但现在积压了许多不愉快的情绪。而这一切，再次证明，都和《奇幻之旅》（Magical Mystery Tour）如出一辙。嘿，拍一部电影能有多难？你知道的，苹果精品店，开一家店卖电影服装能有多难？苹果音乐，开一家店卖电影服装能有多难？
Apple Music. How hard could it be? be to just get rid of the obstacles and let groovy people be groovy. Stick it to the man. Yeah, and without accepting that maybe what made the Beatles great were hurdles and obstacles or added to their greatness. So there's a lot of naivete at this point. It all seems kind of fun now, but I think they're pretty miserable.
苹果音乐。只要扫清障碍，让酷人做酷事，能有多难？去反抗体制吧。对，却不承认也许正是那些坎坷与阻碍造就了披头士的伟大，或者说为他们的伟大增色不少。所以这时候他们身上有很多天真。这一切现在看起来好像挺有趣，但我觉得他们当时其实痛苦不堪。
So John has gone off, and he's got Maroiocho in Gibralton in Spain. He's okay, you can get married into brawling his fame. Christ, you know it ain't easy. So there's a sense there's a sense there of John looking to crucify me. He's recorded Give Piece a Chance with the Plastic Ono band. So there's a sense there of John looking to a musical future after the Beatles. And with Yoko, he is now very into taking kind of radical positions on Vietnam because I think he had recorded a track called Revolution
于是约翰离开了，他和玛丽奥·洋子（Maroiocho）去了西班牙的直布罗陀。他觉得没问题，你可以去直布罗陀结婚并名声大噪。天啊，你知道这并不容易。所以这其中有一种感觉，约翰似乎在寻找自我牺牲。他已经和塑料洋子乐队（Plastic Ono band）录制了《给和平一个机会》（Give Piece a Chance）。因此，这其中有一种感觉，约翰在寻找披头士之后的音乐未来。通过与洋子在一起，他对越南问题采取了激进的立场，因为我想他曾录制过一首名为《革命》的歌，
and he'd sung two versions of it and he said, you can count me out, you can count me in. And he decided to go with you can count me out and felt embarrassed about that. And so he, political activism is something that he's getting increasingly into. You can see kind of a new career direction for him with Yoko. And they've got all these money issues and arguments. And so it looks as if it's all over. But then there is one last glorious hurrah, isn't there? And we are sat here in Abbey Road.
他唱了两个版本，歌里说“你可以把我排除在外”，“你可以把我算在内”。而他决定采用“你可以把我排除在外”那个版本，并为此感到尴尬。所以他越来越投身于政治激进主义中。你可以看到他与洋子在一起后的全新职业方向。他们有着一大堆财务问题和争吵。所以看起来一切都结束了。但随后，还有最后一次辉煌的狂欢，不是吗？我们就坐在阿比路（Abbey Road）录音室里。
I embarrassed you, but I also embarrassed myself by getting you to pose on the zebra crossing outside, which of course is the cover of the album, Abbey Road. Yeah. I only objected because I'm the last person alive to not pose. And now you made me do it. I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry. It's okay.
我让你感到尴尬了，但我自己也很尴尬，因为我让你去外面斑马线上摆姿势拍照，这当然就是专辑《Abbey Road》的封面。对。我反对只是因为我是世上最后一个没摆过这姿势的人。而现在你逼我这么做。我太抱歉了。我太抱歉了。没关系。
But Abbey Road, are you a fan of Abby Road? Of course. Yeah, Abbey Road is fantastic. And again, I don't think Let It Be should have been the last album. It's such a downer, isn't it, compared to Abby Road? There's great songs on Let It Be. And Let It Be was, again, the Beatles being part of something that was really happening, which is, there was music like the band and Credence Clearwater Revival
但《Abbey Road》，你是《Abbey Road》的粉丝吗？当然。对，《Abbey Road》棒极了。而且再说一次，我不认为《Let It Be》应该作为最后一张专辑。比起《Abbey Road》，它太令人沮丧了，不是吗？《Let It Be》里有很棒的歌。而《Let It Be》也是披头士参与时代潮流的一部分，当时有像乐队组合（The Band）和清水乐队（Creedence Clearwater Revival）这样的音乐，
that were stripping it all back, stripping it down, going the other way. So that's what they're doing. They're playing very stripped down. Well, they're getting back, aren't they? They're getting back, yeah, they're getting back. And so that's great, but it's not the heroic ending they should have. It kind of lies the water, doesn't it? Because the songs on Get Back are recorded during the Get Back sessions,
它们在做减法，返璞归真，走向另一个方向。所以这也是他们在做的。他们的音乐非常返璞归真。嗯，他们在回归，不是吗？他们在回归，对，他们在回归。所以这很棒，但这不是他们应得的英雄式的结局。它有点搅浑了水，不是吗？因为《Get Back》里的歌曲是在《Get Back》录音期间录制的，
and it's then released as their final album. But actually the last time that they're in the studio, creating an album, is with Abbey Road. I think the moment on Abbey Road that I find the most moving and, well, it's sad, but it's also triumphantly moving, is you never give me your money, which is Paul singing about, you only give me your funny papers. It's a sense I'm bogged down in paperwork and arguments over finance and cash, and you see there the kind of the horror of the Beatles breakup. And then it's such a kind of classic Paul moment where he suddenly, you know, oh, hang this. we're off and the kind of music soars and they're off on a kind of journey. It's a move that Paul does again and again in his songs where you're down and then you free yourself. That for me is the moment in Abbey Road, that it's an album that is taking wing after you thought that the feathers were tarred forever.
结果却作为他们解散前的最后一张专辑发行了。但实际上，他们最后一次进录音室创作专辑，是在《Abbey Road》。我觉得《Abbey Road》中最让我感动、而且——嗯，虽然有些伤感，但同时也带着一种凯旋般的感动的一刻，是《你从未给过我钱》（You Never Give Me Your Money），那是保罗在唱着“你只给我废纸”。那种感觉就是我陷入了没完没了的文书工作以及关于财务和现金的争吵中，你在那里看到了披头士解散的种种可怕之处。然后这又是那种极其经典的保罗时刻：他突然间，你知道的，“哦，见鬼去吧，我们走”，音乐随即高亢激昂起来，他们开启了一段新的旅程。这是保罗在他的歌曲中一遍又一遍使用的手法：你正处于低谷，然后你解放了自己。对我来说，这就是《Abbey Road》中最动人的瞬间：这是一张在羽翼被永远焦化之后，却重新展翅高飞的专辑。
I was lucky enough to be in the audience for the Saturday Night Live 50th, and I had seats that were way off to the side. So for all the live sketches, I had a pretty good view, but not the best. And then I realized, oh, wait a minute, here comes Paul McCartney to close the show with the final track on Abbey Road. And I'm sitting right there. I'm in the perfect spot. Her Majesty. No, not her magic. Yes, not them, yeah.
我很幸运能成为《周六夜现场》（Saturday Night Live）开播50周年庆典的观众之一，我的座位在非常靠侧边的位置。所以对所有的现场小品来说，我的视野还算不错，但并不是最好的。然后我意识到，哦，等一下，保罗·麦卡特尼上台了，要以《Abbey Road》的最后一曲来为节目收尾。而我就坐在那儿。我坐在绝佳的位置上。《女王陛下》（Her Majesty）。不，不是《女王魔力》。对，不是那个，对。
Okay, you're going to be literal, where they're trading guitar solos. And I got to watch Paul McCartney do that, yeah, out-of-body experience to see him do that and also know that they ended on a perfect note. And I think there are people that moan about how the Beatles could have gone on into the 70s, but I think one of the things that makes them
好吧，如果你非要咬文嚼字的话，就是他们互相飙吉他独奏的那一段。我有幸亲眼看着保罗·麦卡特尼完成那一切，是的，看着他做这件事真是一种灵魂出窍的体验，而且也知道他们是以一个完美的音符完美收官的。我觉得有人会抱怨披头士本可以一直延续到70年代，但我认为让他们成为
a true rarity in show business is their timing was impeccable. impeccable, always. And they ended on this beautiful note and then never came back. And that's one of the reasons that we are still talking about them today. I intend to hang around show business, I already have, long after I've served my purpose, to an embarrassing degree, they timed it perfectly. Do you think also that the news that the Beatles are breaking up comes out in 1970? So, in a sense, the association of the Beatles with the 1960s is absolutely cemented by the fact that they don't survive into the next decade.
演艺界真正的稀世珍宝的原因之一，是他们的时机把握得无可挑剔。无可挑剔，总是如此。他们以这个美妙的音符谢幕，然后就再也没有重组。这也是我们今天依然在谈论他们的原因之一。我打算在演艺界混下去，事实上我早就这么做了，远远超出了我原本的使命，达到了令人尴尬的程度——他们把时机把握得太完美了。你是否也觉得，披头士解散的消息是在1970年传出的？所以，从某种意义上说，披头士与20世纪60年代的紧密联系被彻底稳固了，因为他们并没有存活到下一个十年。
And do you think that's the kind of important part in framing the memory of them, the understanding of them, that they're associated so indelibly with everything that made the 60s kind of vivid and technicolor? I brought up this concept of luck early on. none of this is planned. Think about how short a decade is to us now. At this stage of my life, a decade is so quick. They are in 1960, 61, just really getting started. And in 1969, at the end of the year, they're finishing it up. And that wasn't planned. But like so many things with them, it's what happened and it was perfect. Yes. In history books, 500, years from now, they'll be, if there's a section on the 60s, and there are only three photographs, one of them is going to be of the Beatles.
你是否认为，这是塑造人们对他们的记忆、理解他们的一个关键部分——他们与那些让60年代变得生动鲜活、色彩斑斓的一切事物密不可分？我早些时候提到了“运气”这个概念。这一切都不是计划好的。想想看，对我们现在的视角来说，十年是多么短暂啊。在我人生的这个阶段，十年过得太快了。他们在1960年、1961年才刚刚真正起步。而在1969年，在那个年代末，他们就彻底画上了句号。这并不是计划好的。但就像他们身上的许多事情一样，事情就这么发生了，而且完美无缺。是的。在500年后的历史书里，如果有一个关于60年代的章节，并且只有三张照片，其中一张肯定会是披头士。
So do you think that people will still be listening to the Beatles in 500 years? Yeah, I do. You know, this is with the caveat that we're all still here in 500 years. I hate to be a downer, but one never knows. So unless we're destroyed in a nuclear holocaust, people probably will be. Or I'm tending more towards alien invasion. Oh, the aliens will love the music, but we won't be there anymore. Well, ship us off to a colony on Rizak 7.
所以你觉得500年后人们还会听披头士的歌吗？是的，我会这么认为。当然，这得有一个前提条件：那就是我们大家在500年后都还健在。我讨厌这么扫兴，但世事难料。所以，除非我们在核浩劫中毁灭，否则人们大概率还是会听的。或者我更倾向于外星人入侵。哦，外星人会爱死这音乐的，但我们已经不在了。好吧，那就把我们流放到里扎克7号（Rizak 7）的殖民地上吧。
So this episode is spiraling off in a direction that I hadn't anticipated. No, that's my favorite thing is to take something, unlike the Beatles, I like to take something that is pretty perfect and then ruin it. Not at all. Not at all. With my mad babblings. It's starting to go a bit Plastikono ban. Yeah. That can be good, too.
所以这一集正朝着我没预料到的方向失控。不，我最喜欢的就是拿出一个东西——跟披头士不同——我喜欢把一个本来挺完美的东西给它毁掉。完全没有。完全没有。用我那些疯狂的胡言乱语。这节目开始变得有点像“塑料洋子乐队”了。是的。那也挺好。
That is, I think, in the perfect way to end this episode. Yeah. The 60s are over. The 70s are dawning. Plastikone band is waiting, wings are waiting, all things was past, are waiting, photograph, Ringo's great hit, is waiting. So it's certainly not over for the constituent parts of the Beatles, but the Beatles as a band are over. And I think on that note, Conan, I should thank you very, very much for joining me here in Abbey Road to talk about the Beatles. Well, I think I've made it clear, Restis History is my favorite podcast.
这我想可以说是为这一集画上完美句号的方式了。对。60年代结束了。70年代破晓了。塑料洋子乐队在等待，羽翼在等待，《一切都将过去》（All Things Must Pass）在等待，《Photograph》（林戈的超级大热单曲）在等待。所以对于披头士的各个成员来说，这绝对没有结束，但作为乐队的披头士已经结束了。我想基于这一点，柯南，我应该非常非常感谢你来到阿比路和我一起聊披头士。好吧，我想我已经表达得很清楚了，《历史绝对是个大坑》（Rest is History）是我最喜欢的播客。
So when I got the call, would you be on Restis History? at the studio where your favorite band and your obsession recorded their songs that's a trip I had to make and you said that you were quite keen to be on the rest of history but only with one of us because you wanted to make the other one jealous
所以当我接到电话，问愿不愿意上《历史绝对是个大坑》时？而且是在你最喜欢的乐队和你的精神寄托录制歌曲的录音室里，这是一次我必须成行的旅程。而你说过你其实很想上《历史绝对是个大坑》，但前提是只能邀请我们俩之中的一个，因为你想让另一个嫉妒。
well next time it'll be just Dominic and we'll be doing Beards of the Civil War and you will have to stew alone on your estate while we two yuck it up Dominic is left to reflect on the error of his ways If only he'd been a little more enthusiastic about the Beatles, he could have been here too.
好吧，下次就只有多米尼克（Dominic）了，我们要讲“美国内战时期的胡须”，而你只能孤零零地在你的庄园里生闷气，看我们俩自娱自乐。多米尼克只能反思自己犯下的错误：要是他当时对披头士再热情一点，他也能来这儿了。
Or if he had understood anything about music. Yeah, that's true. And on that tremendous Dominic-oriented note, thank you everyone for watching or for listening. Goodbye. Goodbye. And in the end, the love you take is equal to the love. You'll pay. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
或者要是他稍微懂点音乐的话。对，没错。伴随着这个充满多米尼克风格的精彩结尾，感谢大家的观看或收听。再见。再见。最后，你付出的爱，等同于你收获的爱。谢谢你们。这集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。